字幕: 敏郎 鈴木
校正: Tetsuya Kawaguchi
人間の脳は 左脳と右脳に分かれています
そして それぞれが
違う働きをしています
みなさん お聞きになったこと
あると思います
左脳は主に 理性を司り
右脳は主に 感性を司ると
一般的には言われています
皆さんの中で自分は理性型 自分は感性型と
思われている方も
いらっしゃるかもしれません
どうか 自分が理性型と思う方
心の中で
心の中で 左手を挙げておいてください
心の中で で結構ですよ
自分が感性型と思う方は
右手を 心の中で挙げておいてください
理性型の人は
左脳
こっちかな
皆さんから見て
こっち
感性型の人は 右脳を
発達させているとも よく言われています
しかし 左右の脳がどう働くかということと
皆さんが何を得意とするか
ということは 関係がないんです
皆さんは左右の脳
両方とも使っているんです
それに そもそも理性と感性という言葉
理解して使っているでしょうか
僕は理解していませんでした
そこで
様々な文献
そして様々な研究者たちに会いに行きました
理性って何ですか
感性って何ですか
理性が何か という答えは
早くに分かりました
それは考える ということです
当たり前だと思われるかもしれません
でも感性とは何ですか
という質問に対しては
出会う文献 出会う研究者ごとに
答えが違ったんです
そして ある別のアプローチからの研究が
その答えを出してくれました
ぴったりと はまったんです
感性とは
感情であったり
何かをひらめくという直感であったり
あるいは
物事をありのままに受け止めるという
感覚のことだったりしたんです
もう少し 具体的な説明をしてみましょう
例えば 皆さんが僕のトークを聞いた後に
こんな感想を持たれるかもしれません
あのトーク
このTEDトークとつながるかもしれへんなぁ
これが直感です
なあ・・・
なんであの人 ヒゲなん？
これが感覚です
この説を最初に唱えたのはスイスの心理学者
カール・グスタフ・ユングでした
彼は
人の心の機能としてこの４つ
思考 感覚 感情 直感 があるとしました
そして 一人の人間がこの４つの機能を
すべて持っていると考えたんです
ユングは 人を
思考機能が主な人 感覚機能が主な人
感情機能が主な人 直観機能が主な人 という
４つのタイプに分けはしたんですが
例えば 感情機能が主な人は
その隣の感覚機能
あるいは反対側の隣の直観機能を
併せ持つことがあると主張しています
人を理性型 感性型に分けるのではなくて
心に４つの機能があると考えたわけですね
ところで皆さん
科学者はどういう心の機能を
使っていると思われますか？
考えることが仕事だから
思考機能だと思いますか
今うなずいてくださった方
僕 後でハグしに行きます
ありがとうございます
20世紀を代表する科学者
アルベルト・アインシュタイン
彼は 現代の宇宙論をほぼ完成させた人物です
彼はこんなことを言っています
「私はしばしば音楽で考える」
彼は思考機能と同じぐらい
音楽の才能という直感機能を大切にしたんです
チャールズ・ダーウィンは
宗教観にまで影響を与えた生物学者です
彼は緻密な観察によって
生物が共通祖先から進化するという
進化論を打ち立てました
そして 進化の
構造を支えるDNA
DNAの正体を明らかにしたのは
女性科学者 ロザリンド・フランクリンでした
彼女が撮影した『Photo 51』
という写真を見た３人の男性科学者が
後に ノーベル生理・医学賞を受賞しています
ジャン・アンリ・ファーブルは
昆虫への愛を『昆虫記』という本に書きました
とても情熱的で美しい本です
現代では
ファーブルは科学者として知られていますが
彼は
ノーベル文学賞候補に挙げられていました
マリ・キュリーは
放射能という見えないものへの情熱を
生涯にわたって 捧げ続けた女性です
彼女の研究は学界に認められず
彼女は生活にも困っていたにもかかわらず
１トンもの鉱物の中から
たった0.1グラムしか見つからない
放射性元素ラジウムを ついに見つけたんです
彼女がいなければ 我々の放射能への理解は
何十年も何百年も遅れたことになります
中には万能の人だっています
レオナルド・ダ・ヴィンチは優れた思考能力
研ぎ澄まされた感覚
燃えるような感情 そして
何百年も先を見通す直感力の持ち主でした
彼は今から500年も前に
空を飛ぶことを夢見て
飛行機やヘリコプターの設計をしています
科学という ひとつの営みをとってみても
これだけの心の多様性があるんです
皆さんは 自分自身を
理性型 感性型と
決めつけないでください
それは無意味なことだったんです
どうか心の中で上げた手は
もう降ろしてしまってください
僕は学校の先生に言いたい
学校の先生 よく聞いてください
この子は 思考機能が強いから
理系に向いているとか
この子は 感情機能が強いから
文系だとか
この子は 直感機能に優れているから
芸術系だとか
ましてや
この子は 感覚機能に優れているから
筋肉系だなんて
タイプ分けをしないでください
もしあなたが
学校の先生にそんなことを言われても
忘れてください
例えば 20世紀最高の天文学者
宇宙が膨張していることを発見した人
我々が住む銀河系以外にも
銀河系があるということを証明した
エドウィン・ハッブル
彼は 筋肉系なんです
忘れてください
自分をどんな型だと決め付けなければ
可能性は広がるんです
ユングは心の機能 思考 感覚 感情 直感が
あると言いましたが
そこに明確な線が
引かれているわけではないことも
同時に主張しています
皆さんの
一番得意な機能はどれですか
そして二番目に得意な機能はどれですか
自分を型にはめなければ可能性が見えてきます
レオナルド・ダ・ヴィンチはこう言っています
「優れた画家は２つのものを描く
人と 人の心である」と
皆さんもどうか 自分の心を観察してください
そして 可能性を
見つけてください
聴いてくださってありがとう
（拍手）